من المركز الرابع الاول والمنتخب
الارجنتيني اللي امس تزامنه مع لحظات
وصوله الى العاصمه بيونس ايرس واستعرضنا
معكم الحشود اللي كانوا في استقبال
الابطال والمشاهدات كانت اول مشاهد كانت
حقيقه تفوق الخيال صراحه وخلال الاستقبال
كان في مجموعه من اللقطات الدراميه اللي
صارت مع الفريق ومع الحشود اللي كانوا
متواجدين في الفريق طبعا يتجول في الشوارع
وبالقي التحيه على الحشود وهم على متن
حافله مكشوفه وفي لحظه الاحتفال كان راح
يتحول لكارثه ومسي وزملائه لحقوا حالهم في
اللحظه الاخيره
وينكم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
جدا
واختام الدراما كان بتغيير خطه الاحتفال
فجاه فمن بعد ما كان مقرر انه الفريق يلقي
التحيه على الحشود ويكمل طريقه بالحافله
المكشوفه ليوصل الى وسط العاصمه تغيرت
الخطه تماما لانه من بعد ثلاث ساعات
الحافله ما قدرت توصل الا لي ثلث الطريق
وصلت لمرحله ما عاد تقدر تكمل طريقها بسبب
عدد البشر اللي يقدر باربعه فاصله سبعه
مليون شخص متخيلين الرقم التقديرات في
الاول كانت انه التجمعات حتكون يعني مئات
الالوف مو اكثر ولما اجتمع ملايين انتهت
الحلول على الارض واخذوا اللاعبين بمروحيه
وسلم على الناس من السماء
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الله
اي تمويندو ان الكوبتررو
[موسيقى]
اللي كانت لابسه خلال الاستقبال موقف يخص
حارس مرمى المنتخب الارجنتيني امليانو
ومارتينيز لعام الحاله من الجدل بسبب
حركات السخريه لجالس بيعملها ضد المنتخب
الفرنسي وخصوصا ضد اللاعب كيليان مبابي من
بعد الجدل اللي عملوه بسبب حركه اعتبروها
الفرنسيين غير لائقه بحقهم في الملعب من
بعد الفوز بكاس العالم وطبعا ما بنقدر ان
احنا نعرضها صراحه يعني من الاخر يعني ومن
بعد الفيديو اللي كان ما انت متزاوله في
غرفه تغيير الملابس خاصه ب منتخبه وهو
جالس بيقول دقيقه صمت على روح امبابي
الميت امس كمان عمل حركه جديده فيها سخريه
من مبابي فظاهر خلال الاحتفالات هو حامل
دميه على صوره
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
موقف حارس المرمى الارجنتيني هذا عامل جدل
وانقسم على فكره ففي ناس شايفه احتفال
وعادي ومبرر وناس شايفته يعني اوفر وما في
روح رياضيه ومهين ايضا لزميله
[موسيقى]